ROBIN BENNETT: Users want
both beauty and utility
from their watch faces.
They want bite size information
combined with the style
they love.
If you have an app, adding
a complication data provider
offers a simple way to
engage with users on Wear OS.
Success means you now own a
piece of the screen real estate
that the user wears all day.
My name is Robin,
and I will walk you
through the concept
and development steps
behind a complication
data provider.
One of the cool UI features
of Wear OS by Google
is the watch face.
Users can choose from those
shipped to their device,
or from third party developers.
This provides style,
but what about utility?
In user research,
we found that users
like to access bite size
information from their watch
face.
This can range from the date
to the current temperature.
We call these
complications, a term used
by traditional watchmaking.
One way this can be
done is for each watch
face to make their
own business stills
and bespoke integration
with all the app data
sources that the user
can possibly want.
Clearly, this is not
a scalable solution.
As a result, we created
the Complications API
to connect watch faces
with all the app data
sources on the watch.
There's no need for business
and data format agreements.
They all pass the data
according to an agreed format.
With the Complications
API, the user
can choose the watch face
that expresses their style,
and the data they
find the most useful.
If you have a
mobile application,
think about what is
the one piece of data
the user would most like
to know, and focus on that.
The next step is to see how
that data can be expressed
in the different types.
With Wear OS, we provide a
large variety of choices,
from short text to large image.
Try to support as many
types as you reasonably can.
This will ensure the wider
support from watch faces.
Now that you have decided
what data items to show,
and how they should be
expressed, it's time to code.
To get started, you can
follow the step-by-step code
lab listed here,
and I will highlight
some of the key components
in this code lab.
At its core, a
complication data provider
is a service that extends
complication provider service.
Once the user has selected
your complication data source,
Wear OS will bind to the
service and request data
when it is needed.
There are three methods I
would like to highlight.
First, the
onComplicationUpdate method.
This is called every time the
system requests complication
data.
Since the same data provider
can supply multiple data types,
pay particular attention
to which type of data
is requested before returning.
The second and third
methods are a pair.
onComplicationActivated, and
onComplicationDeactivated.
These methods are optional,
and are usually not used.
They are called when a watch
starts or stops displaying data
from your complication.
If there is data being stored
for a particular instance
of a complication, it can
be set up in activated
and cleared in deactivated.
In addition to the
complication provider service,
two metadata tags in
the Android manifest
are worth highlighting.
The first tells the system
which complication data
types your provider supports.
The second tells the system how
often the complication should
be refreshed.
Two things to note here.
First, although the attribute
is called update period seconds,
think of this period in minutes,
and the longer the better.
This is for battery
conservation.
Second, if your service
receives updates via push,
you can set the update to
trigger at irregular periods
by setting this
attribute to zero,
and instead trigger updates
using provider update
requester.
You can find full details of how
this is done in the code lab.
If you are immobile
app developer,
creating a complication
data provider is
one of the simplest
and meaningful ways
you can support your
users on Wear OS.
Give it a try.
For more details, check
out the code lab mentioned.